I'm not sure who the original author is
but it says a lot about where I am where
I am with my wife and my family and
where we are as a nation eye candy its
life can be a challenge kenzie life can
seem impossible now it's never easy when
there's so much on the line but you can
can make a difference I Love You ed and
thank you well you know a movie is not
good for adults in a way it isn't good
for kids either because this movie it
seems to me is basically just part of
the whole marketing thing I can't
believe I'm actually sort of sticking up
for pokemon but I didn't think it was
that bad i thought the fighting was sort
of controlled i thought there was a
human quality to it I was really moved
at the end when Pikachu teared up and
the final message is about love and
togetherness and hanging in there and
even the villain is transformed okay
well I wish you directed the movie
because I think you've got a better
message that I got out of the movie
flying along just behind the pokeball
comes Pikachu the most recognizable be
over 480 characters in the Pokemon
universe all right Simpsons welcome to
our new home yo yo Santa's Little Helper
is in the house Oh to start us off
tonight NBC News correspondent Colleen
Dominguez on the craze that is now in
Hollywood more than a game play this how
to get to the next level or a top rated
TV show Pokemon is an undeniable
obsession with children across the
country you look Jim Pokemon yeah well
now you can buy your very own I've got
to buy them all furry cat don't you try
pink it chu lam toi collective all that
you can become royal crown
chinpokomaster royal crown
chinpokomaster holy schmow commander its
doors down Chinpokomon is sued by
welcoming the 2006 Pokemon video game
national championship finalist please
give a big I've been a huge fan of
Pokemon since it began and I'm really
excited to be here my son Nick is way
into it I think Pokemon is so popular
because it's pure entertainment for the
kids it's a very positive form of
entertainment it teaches them values and
how to stay focused and team play I
think it's really rude life can seem
impossible